I tend to sort of ponder the blank page
or the half of it and stands or the half
written paragraph and nothing comes and
nothing comes and then an hour later I
begin to say that my whole life is a
failure or you know how could I have
ever thought I was a writer or what
inspires my poetry is other poetry I
mean there's a kind of egotism that's
involved the ego likes to get on the
branch and sing you know it likes to get
up there and it's show it's feathers one
person asked a question to Mandela said
tell me how can you speak with so little
bitterness to the people who are
responsible for your oppression he said
I would not wish what happened to me and
my people on any single human being
that's an inspiration texts watching
people to see the water classical music
the telling of historian the King James
Bible I've come back to so often it was
really translated at a moment where the
English language had an extraordinary
rhythmic and verbal variety we had
grapes growing and ultimately in
September wine was produced
we had olive groves and the red birth we
made out of oil the real flavours of
nature in its most simplest form and
that is I think my palate time and
mortality idealist of the Great Society
program I remember seeing this woman in
a cafe on the corner and she looked like
this what was going on there
you know what do I think was going on
there what you know what can I say about
that getting a writer to talk about his
or her own work it's a little like if
you've ever tried to get a dog
interested in looking in a mirror
especially a puppy who inspires me of
people who are better than me and most
people are better than so there's a lot
of inspiration around for me